[Music]
Ariana Grande is picking up the pieces
after her split from Mac Miller shocking
fans with a candid message about the
breakup on Twitter the 24 year old
singer fired back at one tweeter after
the person seemingly blamed her for
Miller's recent DUI arrest quote how
absurd you minimize female self respect
and self-worth by saying someone should
stay in a toxic relationship ariana went
on to write quote you've cared for him
and tried to support his sobriety and
prayed for his balance for years grande
split from the rapper earlier this month
after nearly two years of dating and a
source tells et but she's now casually
dating Saturday Night Live star Pete
Davidson want to smoke some pot or
something the two has known each other
since at least 2016 when the song
stressed guest hosted the show but back
to Miller an official for the LA Police
Department confirmed e.t last Thursday
that he was arrested without incident
for a misdemeanor DUI after colliding
with a traffic pole the 26 year old
rapper has been open about his sobriety
in the past though in an April 2017
interview with W Magazine Miller
admitted that he'd spent a good time
very sober and was now living regularly
[Music]
up until Ariana's Wednesday tweet it
seemed the exes were still amicable
Ariana even called Mac one of her
favorite people on the planet in a
statement about the break-up
[Music]